-How are you?
-I'm great, man.
How you going?
-Good.
I want to, as always,
ask about "This Is Us,"
but I want
to talk about your movie.
For those
who might not have noticed -
-Those are real puppies.
[ Laughter ]
-Real puppies.
-And the real voice
of Kevin Costner.
-The real voice of
the one and only Kevin Costner
-It's like his inner thoughts.
-Yeah.
-This is not a --
-That was -- yeah, Parker.
Parker's like, "Oh, my God
Kevin Costner's in my head?"
-I know.
Imagine being a dog that young
and your first role
in a movie,
Kevin Costner is your voice.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I think he should quit.
-Probably his last movie.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Did you -- What has --
So, in the course
of the movie --
And again, this isn't a film
where you're
having a conversation
with a dog,
but you do want to hear
what the dog is saying.
Like, Kevin Costner
wasn't on set,
like, standing behind the dog.
-No, no.
I met Kevin on Thursday.
[ Laughter ]
I made the movie last year
-Gotcha.
-Yeah, no, Kevin wasn't on set
I didn't even really
need to hear
what the dog was thinking
because everything going on,
the narration,
was in the dog's head.
-Right.
-All in the dog's head.
So, for me, it was kind of like,
work with the dog, say a line,
and then I'd hear Simon,
our director's like,
"Okay, pause, please."
I'm like, "Interact with the
dog, interact with the dog."
And then -- then like,
"Okay, and action."
And then I say my line.
-Right.
-It was all, like,
there's someone back there
with a clock, going,
"And Kevin's talking,
Kevin's talking.
Kevin's gonna be talking,
and done.
Milo, go."
-That is -- that was the first
time you ever met Kevin
was on Thursday at the premiere?
-Yeah.
-He's a good guy.
-Dude, he's awesome.
-Yeah.
-I was mildly shell-shocked.
Just like, "He's Kevin Costner
I mean, I've been a fan
of everything
that he's done for years."
But he was so warm and so lovely
and supportive of the film
-And it's pretty great, for him,
you just realize
the kind of star he is.
You had to work months
on that movie.
He probably knocked it out
in a day.
-Two days.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He didn't even have to, like
match a talking dog's mout
or anything.
-No. No, no, no.
None of that.
-He was living his best life
yeah.
-I mean, I got to get
some of those jobs.
-You play a racecar driver
in the film.
We've talked in the past
that you love motorcycles.
-Yeah.
-Did you have to do any thinking
about what made a good racecar
driver for this film?
-You know what?
I kind of equated acting -
I kind of, like, took raceca
driving as, like,
laid it right over
being an actor.
You have the same focus,
have the same determination.
You kind of have that huma
spirit to, like, do good.
So that part was easy.
For me, it was more like,
"Hey, let me focus
on being a father,
focus on being a husband.
Let me focus on being
a best friend
to this four-legged pooch.
-There you go.
That works.
-Yeah.
-I know
we were just talking backstage
You just started shooting
this season of "This Is Us."
You had a little bit
of time off this summer.
Did you travel at all?
-I did.
Man, I kind of circled
the globe.
I went -- I was in Japan,
riding motorcycles with a buddy.
-Wow. And so when that --
Excuse my ignorance.
Do you just rent a motorcycl
when you go to Japan?
-Oh, they rented one for me.
-Okay, gotcha.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
Who's "they"?
Like, you just show up in Japan,
it's like, "Here..."
[ Laughter ]
-Actually, I went and rode
motorcycles with Norman Reedus
-Oh, all right, Norman Reedu
from "Walking Dead."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's got a TV show where h
talks about, you know, like,
brings his friends to exotic
places to ride motorcycles
I don't if I was allowed
to say that, but I said it
[ Laughter ]
-Now, "Walking Dead"
and "This Is Us."
Are either of those shows
big in Japan?
Like, are you guys
recognizable fellas?
-People still freak out
when they see Norman.
Still freak out
And, like, for me, it was like
mildly like a lot of bowing.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-Well, with Norman, they
freak out 'cause they think,
like, if he's here,
zombies are close.
-Totally. If I'm here,
it's like, you know,
you're gonna get triplets.
-Yeah.
Or, like, "Oh, no, he's here
Something devastatingly sa
is about to happen."
[ Laughter ]
-They just start crying.
-I want to ask again about
when you ride
your motorcycles in Japan.
Like, what do you --
How much of the day
is spent on the motorcycle
-A lot.
I mean, we were kind of down
near Osaka and Kyoto and Nara,
and so we'd kind of ride around.
But also, really, what Norman'
out to do is just kind of like
experience the cultures.
So I had a bunch of friend
in that part of Japan,
and so I introduced him
to my friends.
And my friends had friends
and before we know it, we're at,
like, a furniture maker's shop
-Wow.
-And I'm looking at chairs
and I'm picking them up
while cameras are rolling.
I'm like,
"Can I get four of these?"
-I can't decide if that make
total sense or no sense
that you would
start on a motorcycle
and end up at a furniture shop
[ Laughter ]
It maybe makes total sense
-Yeah.
-It seems like people who woul
want to tinker around
with motorcycles might als
want to, like, make a table.
-Yeah. I think so.
I mean, woodworking and grease
-Exactly.
Do you ever --
Are you somebody --
Are you ever going at a spee
in which we should
be fearful for you?
-Yes.
-You do?
-Yeah.
-See, that's why --
I don't -- My wife rides
a motorcycle, and I don't.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
I don't even like
going on a bike downhill.
[ Laughter ]
-But see, here's the thing, Seth
-- bikes, to me,
feel more dangerous
than motorcycles.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-Listen,
I can't convince you otherwise
-Yeah, that's why people
on regular bikes
wear those giant helmets.
[ Laughter ]
-I think they should.
-Yeah.
-They should totally wear
the big giant, like,
can't see me,
don't know who I am.
-How much thought do you put
into, like, the --
And, again,
this is no judgment zone -
the outfit on your motorcycle.
Are you, like,
somebody who wants to look -
like, match as cool
as the bike is?
-No, I don't care about
how it looks.
I'm all about safety.
-Okay.
-As I just admitted
that I speed.
Which I don't entirely
all the time.
-Gotcha.
-No, for me, it's always ful
sleeves, full face helmet,
boots, some kind of like jeans
or denim or something.
And, like, take your time.
-All right, gotcha.
So the first time you're ridin
a new kind of bike,
do you have
to be careful with it,
or are they sort of
all the same?
Okay, gotcha.
-No, they're all different
They're all different.
Your bike kind of becomes
an extension of you.
Like, that's the thing.
So when I was in Japan,
and I was riding with Norman
it was like -- they put me -
I'm like, "Please just put m
on a Harley-Davidson."
I really just wanted to be
on a Harley-Davidson,
because that's what I'm familiar
with is with Harley-Davidsons.
So, they put me on a Harley,
but still, it was just --
It was just different.
-Right,
because of the exchange rate
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Yes.
The exchange rate.
That's exactly --
-Yeah, I'm sort of a --
I'm a grease guy, too.
-Yeah, totally.
[ Laughter ]
-You know how it all ends
with "This Is --"
Do you know
how this season ends,
or do you sort of know
the whole --
-I know, like, the far off -
-You know the far off, gotcha.
-But it's also,
that's what I've been told
-Right, so it can change.
-Things can always change.
It's a newspaper.
You got to wait and see
what's gonna happen.
But what I do know?
I mean...
-Do you --
[ Laughter ]
-It is really, truly beautiful
-Do you like having the burden
of knowing a thing that's so -
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Who does?
-Yeah.
-It's like carrying, like, you
know, the nuclear football
It's like, this is the thing
that destroys the world.
-Yeah.
And obviously, one,
I would assume
there's so many people
who want to get it out of you.
-Yes.
-And, two, there would be
so many people
that would be furious at you
if that's how it went down
-Yeah, probably,
so I'm just gonna shut my mout
and not say a word.
Actually, I don't know anything.
I'm just gonna play,
like, stupid actor.